british french relations were already
bad enough the fishing row souring the
mood over the channel with french
vessels out in force all day and protest
and demonstrators blockading the channel
tunnel
but it's the aftermath of this week's
migrant tragedy that has plunged
relations to another low
two days after 27 died trying to cross
to britain the two governments who
should be working to prevent it
happening again are doing the opposite
when boris johnson met his polish
counterpart this morning there was no
sign of contrition you as i think
probably our closest
european nato ally but the prime
minister's decision to tweet this letter
before sending it to emmanuel macron has
left the french president exasperated
i'm surprised by the methods when
they're not serious
we do not communicate from one leader to
another on these issues by tweets and
letters that we make public
we are not whistleblowers in a statement
french interior minister gerald dominar
said we consider the british prime
minister's public letter unacceptable
and contrary to our discussions between
counterparts
veteran british diplomats have also
condemned the move the context to all
this is an enormous loss of trust
between paris and london
and so i think boris johnson's decision
to send out his letter by tweet
even before emmanuel macron had received
it if we understand correctly
was a real blunder because it led the
french to think that this was more about
grandstanding to the british public than
engaging in serious diplomatic
discussions with france over some
extremely difficult issues affecting
people's lives pretty patel who was
going to cali to meet french officials
on sunday to discuss greater cooperation
has been uninvited the prime minister
spokesman says he hopes the french
reconsider that decision and reinvite
the home secretary before sunday but he
stands by tweeting that letter saying
the public wants to know what the
government is doing
two days after this tragedy british and
french governments are exchanging
recriminations their efforts to meet and
find a way forward seem paralyzed by a
diplomatic row
dominic waghorn sky news